did you know that all stellar mass black  holes are smaller than the moon  of course the supermassive ones at the  centers of galaxies are bigger the one  at the center of our own galaxy is 17  suns wide  though it's smaller than a typical giant  star so it's still smaller than you were  probably imagining but those have been  around a long time  stellar mass black holes are the fresh  ones that form from stars and have the  mass of a typical star  those are all way smaller than you think  the smallest ones are about three times  the mass of our sun but they're only the  size of a city  the largest ones weigh in at about 200  times the mass of our sun and they're  still smaller than our moon  so you know just something to think  about the next time you hear about black  holes